[Music]
welcome everyone
hello to this new live stream of firm
learning here on the channel
great to see the first people dropping
in right now apologies for looking maybe
a little bit lost because it's the first
time i'm using this specific streaming
setup
which i'm not that familiar with um hope
it works all well
so i'm doing this here today instead of
the regular weekly video because i just
thought that given that about two weeks
ago we reached the new milestone of 150
000 subscribers this should be very much
worth another little live stream like
this one
so thanks for the first of you joining
zeo medsec thank you for writing already
a message in the chat looking forward to
hear from many others of you as well
feel free just to say hi just that i see
that you are here i would indeed very
much appreciate it
um
study life hi great that you're here as
well
i will actually also just try to join
here just to see that it all
works
karanbia thank you also for your message
great to see more people dropping in
here
vincent greetings from mines awesome
kwame hello
hello to you as well
um
yeah i guess we just wait a couple of
seconds for everyone joining i have a
couple of topics he prepared for you
today that i want to talk about but as a
heads up
um so vincent looking forward to
internship in munich that's awesome
valent
nikhil great that so many of you are
joining love it that's that's amazing
and kately welcome as well hello you of
course too
um and
so what do we for sure do so two things
that we will do today so the first is a
cv review
so i received a couple of cvs over the
last weeks and months from people that
are occasionally reviewing live streams
like this so like two or three or so
prepared that i will go over here with
you
and we're going to look into that and
then of course a part of that will also
be a
live q a
um so you will all have the
opportunities to just ask questions i
will likely not be able to answer every
single one that you are asking here in
the chat
but if you have a question feel free to
just
drop the question in here in the chat
and then i will pick up a couple of them
and of course if you uh decide to do a
so called super chat as i believe it is
called which pretty much just means
tipping with a couple of bucks or so
we'll prioritize your question then for
sure make sure that we get that one
answered
so see even more people dropping in
mattia
nikki we already had you
tamim ko sheikh
great that so many of you are joining
very much looking forward to conduct
this session with you it is filling in i
think now about 60 people here in the
stream
of course welcome to another coffee chat
also hope uh you all
can help yourself to a cup of tea or a
cup of coffee something like this for
today's session great that so many of
you are here already
joining
it can you just also let me know in the
chat i mean is it all working well the
audio okay is the video okay
because as i said um i'm using your new
setup new camera some new lights and so
on
so far i'm afraid the only benefits of
this new setup is that you can see my
my eye rings i guess in super high
resolution
but still it is it is what it is i guess
um so um chat is good that's awesome
awesome stuff
um so yeah actually let's let's maybe
just start by
by writing down a couple of things
which
i want to accomplish here with you today
let's see if this works it does seem to
work indeed
so what what will we do what is the plan
here for
for the day shirt under a hoodie indeed
you know it's the weekend look so we
need to do what we we need to do
um so
what's the plan for today so let's just
do a brief channel
recap given that we are at 150 plus
subs just want to briefly talk about
that
let's also
do a brief welcome
to
the new
channel members
so far i haven't seen any chat messages
from channel members so if there's any
member here in the chat please just let
me know just write something in the chat
would love to see you here participating
as well i very much appreciate it and of
course if anyone else wants to become a
member just click the join button
and i even included a new member here
where really for a very minimal symbolic
amount you can just become a member
would love that
um
next for today's plan let's do some
channel
feedback so there are a couple of points
where i'd love to get your feedback on i
will talk about that in a moment but
let's look at that as well
then i will do as promised a cv review
so i received a couple of cvs from
several of you um so i do want to look
at that look at what you guys are
writing here let's look at some
cv reviews and then we can i guess
together
provide a little feedback to these
ladies and gentlemen to do exactly that
and
then we will do a let's just say a
career and consulting
q a so all of you can just ask questions
here in the chat i will not be able to
pick up every single one
um
but yeah let's do that and let's get
that done and see more people joining so
claus
said m
peter live idea absolutely hope it's
going well for all of you as well
um
so who else do we have here many other
people for sure
okay whatever so let's do the channel
recap so yeah i started the channel in
january 2020
so at the time i was out of consulting
out of mckinsey at the time for a couple
of months you know while of course at
that time i was working as a cto's chief
transformation officer
surely the job also was time consuming
but i wasn't working as late in the
evenings as i was used to in my time in
consulting
and for these reasons i pretty much just
decided to start
this youtube channel right just to fill
the evenings it was also at the
beginning of the lockdown side a little
bit time more time for myself it was
just a funny little idea i didn't really
have much that i planned for at the time
and then
the first six months or so i got a
couple of thousand subscribers i believe
i mean check out the very early videos
that i created on the channel right if
you want to see how it all started i
think it's also always fun just to look
back how that all worked right i think
it's just funny to see that
and
of course super grateful for how it all
developed for me it really was a
great impact on my personal life that
this channel made
so just every second week or so so
people are approaching me in munich uh
talking about the channel that's of
course always great to interact with you
on the streets uh get to know some of
you are very very much appreciate that
um so yeah that's quite just great
so the node application that i'm using
is just the
the windows notepad app right so just as
basic as it gets
but that's that's what it is right
and um
so yeah this is what i've been doing
with the channel continue to create
weekly videos for you hope you
appreciate it hope you like the content
and um but this is something where i
would love to get your feedback on right
because i mean over the last months and
years i was creating lots of content
about consulting topics about career
topics i'd love to get some uh some
feedback from you feel free to just
write in the chat or maybe also just
afterwards shoot me an email or whatever
if you have any other ideas of maybe
also other topics that you would be
interested to get my uh insights on
maybe also topics that are not super
deeply related to consulting right so
i'd love to maybe also expand a little
bit more and more adjacent topics as
i've already done of course with some of
also my past
videos so if you have any ideas on that
any things that you would suggest me to
do i would really much appreciate that
and then maybe just another thing i
would be very curious um i would be very
curious maybe just to pick up a couple
of questions so would you recommend prep
launch it's actually i would i mean i
made a video with them
end of last year i think they're great
service i think preparation also more
case studies is really a great way of
preparing for case interviews so feel
free to pick that up
um
and then someone else is asking for
quotas for women
so i think different firms handle this
in a different way so also not not
knowing the very strict internals
but i'd say surely it doesn't hurt at
the moment to be a woman right if you
want to break into consulting let's just
put it this way
but um yeah just some other things i
would love to get your insights your
your feedback your tips on is also what
i've been doing on my channel with these
little short videos so if you've been
watching uh the channel lately you've
seen that i release several let's say
short form videos on the youtube channel
so these youtube charts this is what
they are called
um so what i'm wondering actually is do
you enjoy them do you like them because
frankly what i'm a little bit afraid is
that maybe some people might even find
them annoying don't really want to see
them
that maybe some people just maybe
dislike it if these types of videos pop
up
on their home page on the youtube page
on their suggested page just give me a
little feedback like what do you think
on these short videos because i think
they have fun like just a little thing
just to spice it up also an easy way of
course for me to just create additional
videos on top of just the weekly videos
that i want to create for you
so if you just give me a feedback
because of course i don't want to put
anyone off um but yeah i see first
comments shorts are very good
really like the shorts thank you vincent
castellan tamo writing your shorts are
great good information cops huels
helpful and excellent
um all right i'm happy to hear that of
course and actually by the way so what
i'm doing here with these uh with these
short videos is that actually there are
much more short videos that that i'm
that i'm doing that i post on my youtube
so my youtube i just try to post a
selection of all the short videos that i
do because as maybe some of you already
know i am active
on both instagram and tick tock so the
handle
is what i'm writing here in
the chat right so from learning on
instagram tick tock and on those
platforms actually i'm posting even more
short form videos
um so if you're interested to see even
more just feel free to check out these
two platforms
uh and then to get more out of it okay
adrian you're saying they lack value
this of course not great sorry to hear
that
um
maybe adrian feel free to just provide a
couple of more comments on like what
exactly maybe you don't like or what
maybe also what type of short videos you
would enjoy watching
uh definitely interested to get some
more yeah insights on that what i could
improve here because surely this is
something that i just started out
and um yeah that would be great to know
would be fun but again check out the
tick tock and instagram to maybe watch
even more of this is what's what's
interesting to you and violent your
writing is it possible to direct message
you i mean in principle it is you can do
that either on my linkedin or on my
instagram probably these are the best
two
two channels i might not always be able
to
answer straight away i think especially
my instagram at the moment i have quite
a backlog of messages
but every other week or so i just try to
pretty much clean up all the messages
that i received there so feel free to
get that done and osama you're saying uh
i speak a bit too quickly in the short
so i should speak slower
that's also an interesting one so on
many of my youtube videos i get feedback
or comments that i speak too slowly i
mean obviously like this is the number
one comment i get from you on all my
youtube videos that you feel like my
english sucks pretty much so sorry for
that i really try hard to improve my
accent and make this as easy to aim to
understood as possible
so just did it make a little bit of an
effort to maybe speak a little bit more
quickly on my shorts just also to not
yeah make it too boring
maybe some other people might also have
more opinions on that
but yeah these are some things i'd love
to um to get your insights on
um
last or maybe the next thing as you see
here i mean i think this is your the
point on the feedback right i think the
next thing i want to talk about
something this is done
channel feedback this is done
maybe also just want to say
really like a warm welcome and also
thanks to all the new people who
joined the channel right so um because
as you maybe know i have this membership
program where people can join the
channel but doing that you just support
me i also added a new membership here
where really literally just for a couple
of like i think two euros something like
this per month you can just support and
become a member of course i very much
appreciate that um i think the last
people who joined are shahran so thanks
sharon for joining daniel thanks to you
for joining as well
brian thanks to you for joining carlos
thanks to you for joining lana's lessons
learned thanks to you of course as well
nelson tty johnny john
ivan aditia
nirvana kevin marge
those are the ones who joined in the
last month or so so very much
appreciated that that all of you are
joining supporting the channel by doing
that
um
so yeah and again all the others if you
want to join as well just click the join
button and you see the details just a
short little way of contributing to the
channel supporting that is very much
appreciated of course
so i think we have covered
that one as well indeed
um so let's pick up a couple of your
questions
and i see frankly that you already wrote
like far too many questions for me to
answer
so as i said in the beginning i mean if
you want to have your question
prioritized for free just to make a
message with a little tip i think it's
called the super chat and then i will
make sure that your message is answered
for sure
but let's pick up a couple of the ones
that i see here in the chat
um i mean i think earlier there were a
couple of people asking on my mba or my
mba experience whether it was
worth it or not i mean frankly my mba at
the time was sponsored is partly
sponsored by my employer at the time
right so i didn't pay it completely out
of pocket i think for me the decision to
really pay it completely out of pocket
would for sure have been a much more
difficult decision for me so for me the
the the thought process at the time was
just you know i had this opportunity to
do this mba i still paid also still a
significant amount
and but the question was so do i do it
right because i already had a business
undergraduate degree and at the time i
also already had a finance master so
before i joined consulting at jordan
mckinsey i had a master degree in
finance at the london school of
economics and then i wondered so should
i do an mba i mean is it even really
necessary i'm probably just from a
strict content perspective so surely i
learned new things surely there were
some great insightful courses but my
thought process at the time was rather i
mean what are the choices i can now skip
the mba instead just work the year right
i mean just get another year of work
experience in during the time
but i asked myself so what would really
make a difference for me maybe like 10
years or 20 years down the line right so
if i like look back at my life in 10
years or 20 years what is likely to have
really have have a great impact on my
life on my personal development my
profession and also private personal
development
is it having worked an additional year
or is it having spent one year you know
with other professionals and then i did
this insead one ncr mba as you know
which was for me spending half the time
in singapore in asia traveling a lot
really getting lots of new input and to
me it was clear that likely this
additional year probably would have had
a bigger impact the chances that this
really makes a difference for me and
that this really provides some great
insights for me
this was quite high right and surely it
was a great year i learned a lot asia
for me was really a distant place before
i did the nba i only was there a handful
of times for holiday for a couple of
weeks so this really opened my eye in
many different ways i met lots of great
people that still are very good friends
today some people that also now move to
munich live here that i still regularly
see
and so for me it definitely was worth it
of course the question is always also
financing surely i was in a lucky
position at the time to get a very good
financing for the program
if you really are cash constrained and
you really depend on
needing to recover the amount that you
spend for the nba in a couple of years
afterwards
uh i think that i mean this is just the
stress that maybe is not worth it then
rather continue to
to work and maybe make sure that you're
just in a good financial position where
uh such an amount for the mba the
tuition fees don't put you in a very
significant amount of stress so thinking
about needing to take out a loan to
finance it i mean that's really tough
right i mean would you really want to do
that i mean here of course the the
situation is very you need to look at
the independent situation whether this
makes sense for you but surely if this
is what i would have needed to do
the decision would have been much more
difficult for me than what i indeed did
then in the end okay
so harness you're asking how important
is fast math in my head for consulting
so actually that's funny because um i
created a video about that um a couple
of months ago i think i called it like
dirty tricks or like sneaky little
tricks that you can apply in consulting
so if you wonder whether
what you can do maybe if your mental
math isn't that great just check out
this video because i shared a couple of
sneaky tips on how you can let's say
fake some mental math to put it this way
right just to perceive it i mean i think
the truth is that mental math is always
if you're good at mental math that is
always perceived of being very
intelligent
so if you just do some like crazy
calculations in your head everyone will
think like both your team your partners
your project leads but also the clients
i know this guy or this lady he or she
must be really smart
so so that being said probably mental
mars also wasn't my special strength
um so you definitely can get away
without it
but it's a help if you can do it but
it's not absolutely required right so
it's it's not that if you cannot do it
it's a big problem it just helps doing
that
and so silverhawk now great to see a
member here in the chat thanks for for
joining thanks for your question very
much appreciate
your support for sure right and you are
asking
any good tips on how one can improve
the questioning skills during client
interviews
actually i think i created a video
specifically on this topic so
specifically on the topic of
doing interviews right i mean there are
lots of things i could talk about i
think probably it's best just to to
check out the video i think it's called
something about interview tips or
something like that
so feel free just to check out um the
channel if you if you look for interview
tips a video on that
you should find find it address right
um so raunak is saying you have the same
question as rohan and rohan you are
asking
how would you recommend doing a new smba
if you if i'm working in an mbb firm in
india after undergrad
um i think in general just the truth
with the mbas is probably two things to
have in mind the first list and this is
probably like the leading thing that you
should ask yourself probably the better
the reputation the the better right i
mean the value of an mba
even more i would argue than your
undergraduate degree or maybe just the
more regular master the value of your
mba is just very very very much linked
to uh the reputation of the university
right and so surely like the big u.s
names have like the the best reputation
so something like
harvard stand for what and these are
surely the top names and then in the us
as a tier 2 probably things like
yeah colombia and so on right so all
these other names i trust you know then
colombia mit and so on and so forth so
now in europe probably the best to our
london business school insa those are
the ones that i would apply to and then
all the others ah i mean yeah of course
you can't know nambia and bocconi ese
and so on
but
i mean of course depends on your goals
but if you're really like if you're
really like you know in this tier one
league and really like looking to polish
your profile for like mbb firms already
like tier one banking private equity
firms
i would really doubt whether the return
on invest is that great if you do an mba
that is not really part of this tier one
league again it can depend a bit on on
your goals maybe these are not your
goals and that might work but i think if
you're doing an mba um not for not at
one of these really like tier one
leading universities often the value is
not really there
consulting you more thanks for joining
as well appreciate it check out this
channel guys consulting new mouse on
instagram hilarious content right
um but back to the to the mbas um so
just check that out i think it very much
depends on the reputation
um
also if you put it in perspective to the
tuition so i think if you pay a similar
tuition as as these two one programs pay
and then you're not getting the value
from the reputation then i think you
need to ask yourself whether it's worth
it
and um
but of course maybe this is also not
your objective and maybe then you're
fine also with a slightly cheaper
program right and then it's okay this
way
good
rohan follow-up you're asking whether
it's worth it to do an mba at all i
think i talked a little bit about doing
the value of doing an mba earlier so
we'll not repeat that and maybe just
later look back at the recording if you
have a question on that
um i will later pick up many more of
your questions
i just thought let's do the following
and this is let's
let's review some cvs right because like
over the last weeks and months i got
several cvs that i got sent
let's just switch to an even other
perspective
um
so if by the way you want to have your
cv included in
future setups as well
um feel free just to write me an email
so if you go to my youtube channel to
the about page of my youtube channel
there is an email address i think it
says
please only use for commercial inquiries
but if you want to send me your cv you
can also use this email address
if you want me to review your cv just
two things to keep in mind first
please just anonymize it so i really
don't want to see like too many personal
informations of yours so as this lady or
gentleman i don't even know uh
did it here so you can see that like all
the personal information is sanitized is
rejected so i don't want to see your
name i don't want to see your personal
details any personal telephone number or
anything like that right so just take
all of this out and then of course
second if you sent me your cv you agree
that i'm allowed to show it right to a
large audience to use it on all my
social media channels and so on so as
long as you're okay with that that's
fine send it to me and then occasionally
i will do live streams like this
where i discuss these things
all right now i want to do the following
so you see the cv here right and
what i want to ask you to do first
just based on first impression so just
like now without looking at the content
i want to hear from you in the chat
how do you rate this cv on a scale from
1 to 10 so 10 being best one being worst
so
rate the cv
one
from 1 to 10 one like worst
ten life best
what do you say from one to ten
one worst ten best like how great is
this cv just let me know would very much
be interested in your opinion on this
so here five eight
five
four
that's interesting right so many
different views interesting stuff cool
to hear cool to hear
all right
see
let's just go over it i'm to be uh
very frank so i didn't really look at
the ecb's in detail right so so before
this live stream let me maybe also just
put on my glasses just to help me to
look at this
so i like only very briefly looked at
this to hopefully make sure that there
are no like very like personal details
anything included
um so it's also for me more or less now
live reacting to this
um i mean my first reaction is
what i like is really this nice one
pager format so i think in general if
you apply for professional services for
consulting banking and so on try to
stick to this one page of format it's uh
usually much better than having like two
or three pages or something like that it
just seems more professional and i think
anyone who has ever reviewed cvs it's
just so much easier for you as the cv
reviewer to have everything on one page
no need to go back and forth everything
like neatly organized just much nicer
okay just try to stick to this one page
um let's let's look at that but still
this having said if you just look at the
formatting
overall ah just the very first
impression
it doesn't really look like very
polished very nice it looks a bit
unclean
like peter right you're also saying not
formatted properly i mean it's not like
the first impression is it's not really
polished right and maybe let's just look
at a couple of things so what does
contribute to the whole thing
not looking very
polished
and here i mean the first thing that
just pops up is things like
alignment and
equal spacing
so here for instance
i mean here just on on the logical sense
so the first hierarchy of bullets seems
to be this
this like bold and then underlined so
your summary education causes experience
but then you can see
there like inconsistencies in the
formatting so for instance
if this is now the the first like
highest level of logic why is it the
case that here between summary and
location there's such a line
between courses and experience there's
such a line
between experience and extracurriculars
there's such a line
but why isn't there a line between
education and courses that's illogical
right that doesn't make sense i mean
it's just like
from a logical perspective a mistake i
mean
it's not formatted consistently
right
another thing equal spacing so here you
see
the spacing of so how much space there
is right between the different elements
i mean this should all be consistent
here between summary and education
there's very little space between this
and this line i mean here this p from
the impact is almost touching the line
right whereas then for instance here if
you look at the the distance from the
text here to the line here there's a
lots of distance so the whole spacing
not really consistent just doesn't just
doesn't look polished i mean these are
lots of small things but they add up
just also to the first impression that
you see here
just a couple of additional things here
the dates
here you see the dates are
in bold
right bold and big here the dates are
not bold
and small
why is this the case inconsistent
doesn't make sense also here see how
zap here they use an abbreviation
and here they use the full it's fully
written out much
why why do they do that i mean come on
like doesn't make sense at all it's just
inconsistent
um
also here now the red since
ah i mean just so many so many little
things that that you notice here some of
you are writing the font size i also
fully agree i mean i think it's a
general best practice to try to really
stick to a uniform font size
but if you use different font sizes at
least make sure that elements on the
same logical level have the same font
sizes so if this is now the big logical
level of this main thing why doesn't
summary have the same song size as
education
doesn't make sense
also your bullet points if you do is um
i mean
usually if you do bullet points you want
to have at least two bullets
to really use bullet points if you don't
have two bullets like in one package
rather take out the bullet point and
make it a proper text
also here problems with indentation
so these things are not properly aligned
i mean if you like try to build some
logical lines here i mean this year
starts on the same level as p the
programmer but here there seems to be an
additional
space
right an additional space here
that for instance here is missing so
here this is not a line not indented
properly you see this again also here
this electrical engineering not sure
maybe my visuals are leaving me here but
this doesn't seem to be neatly starting
here at the other e
here there seems also to be a space
sitting here
someone is autobahn hour you're pointing
out some dates are all caps others not
yeah exactly something now on the
formatting we now uh mention our many
different things
so this is just not nice and clean right
so let's make sure that this is
cleaned up and
i think there's also i mean also here on
the bullets notice how these bullets are
not indented properly not start at the
same height
i mean i don't know if i'm too picky on
this i mean maybe let me know in the
comments i mean if you were to receive a
cv with all these formatting i mean
what's your reaction i mean do you feel
like i'm exaggerating or do you feel
like
uh
an average cv reviewer wouldn't even
notice all these things i mean what what
is
what is your opinion on that because i
mean i can just tell you
i mean just just let me know before i
give you my perspective
um justified criticism i mean again i
can just tell you um
just from my experience in consulting i
mean if you create documents like that
like imagine this would be a document
that you sent to a client i mean
whatever just the one page memo just the
one page document right that you that
you share
i mean one thing is for sure if you send
it like this if you prepare it like this
uh
i mean like your project lead would come
to you and tell you like what the heck
is this i mean didn't you didn't you
even invest the minimum amount of effort
just to polish it to make it look nice i
mean this is just not client ready this
is just not ready to be sent to a client
and at least from the professional
services perspective if you would send
this to a client i mean this would just
not be acceptable right and of course i
would argue again i never worked in the
cv screening department of any
consulting firm so of course you know
you pick up a couple of things but i
never i never really myself selected
cv's income inconsistent right so i
don't know for sure but i would argue
that these are exactly the things that
then the gentlemen and ladies who look
at these things also
look out for um
because they are just a bit lazy and a
bit sloppy
okay
um
shall we do a second one what do you
think
let's look at the second one
no comments in the chat whatever let's
just do it anyway
um i think there's a little bit of the
delay between the chat and what i say
but anyway here's a second one let's do
the same little exercise so i just show
you the cv
and actually this is now two pages
and here again first impression let me
know on a scale from one to ten first
impression
just one not that great
ten perfect awesome right so from one
very bad 10 awesome cv how would you
rate it let me know from one to ten
again without really reading the details
of the content just first impression
like well what do you see of this
from one to ten what is your impression
see a couple of comments too long okay
here's on average the ratings seem to be
a bit lower
than the other cv let me just scroll
down again
um
visual saying 1990s looking cv
toward it wordy three two four three
interesting right
interesting interesting
so yeah let's also just just look at
that
and i mean
so here my my first comment would be
once again on the point of one page of
versus two pager so i think my my
general point would be
try again try to go for one page or
whenever possible i think the two pager
is really the maximum that you should do
so never do more than two pages but i
would argue even if you are a super seen
seasoned professional like 30 40 years
of work experience or so you will always
be able to put a cv like on one page
it's always possible and if this means
that maybe you leave out some things
that aren't relevant maybe some things
that are not really needed anymore but
it's always possible to put it on one
page right and especially if you don't
even make proper use of the second page
i mean this is maybe only like one third
of the second page used especially then
make sure that then you maybe condense
it a little bit more
um and then just put it on one page
right
and then i think the
the second uh comment that you are
making
looks like a report
i mean with that i also agree it's super
long
um
i mean just i mean imagine you are being
the one who needs to read this when you
look at this ah i mean you're already
somehow annoyed just looking at that
right because now you really need to
just read through all of this
i mean you know imagine you sitting at
your desk having like a big pile of cvs
that you need to read you ideally just
want to briefly skim them see does this
make sense does this not make sense like
does this meet the profilers does not
meet the profile and then you need to
just read all of this are you already
exhausted before you even start it i
mean this at least i would imagine
someone reacting if you look at this
and i mean it also now shows potentially
um
just one lack of a skill that you have
and this is to
that you apparently or maybe you're not
able to not distinguish the important
pieces for of information from the not
so important pieces of information you
failed like apparently you needed to
write all of this even though probably
only half
probably would be able to condense all
of this and only half of the number of
the bullets
so um so in germany you would say
schwerpentzetsu i mean all the lawyers
know if you if you write exams in law
good art and still you write like these
big
legal assessments in your legal exams
you know like one key skill that you
need to show is that you are able to
distinguish the important things that
are relevant to the case from the not so
important things that are relevant to to
the case right so just visiting from nic
so the lawyers will know what i'm
talking about and apparently this is of
course a problem here that has been
missing of course then also a little
like things like this dot here like this
extra dot i mean of course this is only
a minor thing
but i mean come on i mean this means
that if you do a cv and then you you
leave this
i mean you you didn't even bother right
to just look at the final pdf
just to spot that here there's an empty
bullet i mean you didn't even bother to
open just i mean it just you see this as
first sight right just to open this
document and look at it
i mean that's indeed a little bit lazy
like obviously doesn't really look good
um
what i do like just in principle is to
some extent how at least some of these
bullets have been written i mean here
you see that many bullets focus really
on on impact what has been achieved ri
lots of numbers in the bullets i mean
this is actually something um that i
would argue is great and this is
important and something i would always
encourage you to do right i think um
so whenever you write bullets an error
that many people do is that they focus a
lot on so the activities so what were
the things that you did so i i led this
initiative i led that initiative i
looked at this i wrote this report wrote
that report i let maybe this and at that
whatever all these things
um what do you instead should focus on
much more is really the impact what are
the tangible
measurable results that you created for
the business i mean this is really what
it should all come down to and this is
what i think this has been done to some
extent quite well with lots of numbers
mentioned i mean this i think it's just
a simple thing try to include a number
and almost all of your bullets this
already will help you to just push
yourself really finding something with
some impact that you were able to show
just pushes to you to really make it
measurable and this is really something
that i like in here so
all right um
i mean uh
just in terms of also
right so what are the things that have
been talked about in here maybe what are
the things that have not really been
talked about in the cv
i mean what i
what i
do think that is noteworthy i mean while
i agree that if you are a professional
and already worked
um several years and so on surely also
we should focus
on on your work experience as also has
been done here
um
they would argue that probably you can
just invest like a little bit more space
on your education than just like one
line but especially if you really only
have one degree so only one point that
you want to talk about in your education
i mean
maybe you just talk a little bit about
leadership positions that you had just
some extracurricular stuff this i think
in general is a cv section that to some
extent is missing extracurriculars
extracurricular activities that's of
course always great to include and
usually most people will find something
that they can talk about so try to do
exactly that
um
to just make this look a little bit more
around it right to just
just also show that there are things
that you did in your life beyond just
your professional work that you're not
just focused they're not just about all
about work but i was a bit more rounded
character
which often also also consulting awesome
professional services companies indeed
indeed like to see
okay maybe just the last thing that
could be included is i mean just
some section on on just other other
skills
i mean also if you watched some of my
older videos on cvs where i share a
couple of tips on how i believe a cv
should be structured what the things are
that you should include i mean typically
a small section on for instance language
skills or maybe also some i.t skills
other qualifications would make a lot of
sense
and i would argue someone with the
apparently an engineering degree
probably will have lots of skill signals
to show for again just like a short
section nothing too extensive you can
easily fit these things also into one
pager
but these are things that
that work well and really make a lot of
sense
um
okay
all right next one
um one more cv
[Music]
one more ceviche we look at one
additional cv uh to look at to truly
digest here
yes luis writes no
lorenzo one more more okay wrench said
yes
all right or maybe let's do the
following
thing um
because actually i think we are now
already talked for
uh for a couple of time
let's maybe make make make a break for
now
um
i think i see with we already also
talked for 40 minutes let me drop off
here so thanks very much for all your
support i very very much appreciate it
um i'd say let's let's make a break
very much appreciate all your support
and let's spare the last cv for for
another day
um i very much appreciate it
and um
let's continue like this so thanks for
all of you being so active that's really
great thanks for all your nice comments
i very very much appreciate it thank you
and looking forward to the journey to
continue this journey
and
see how we indeed
looking forward to all the videos i have
in store for you next
all right thank you and cheers bye-bye